i'm i'm very very concerned about the
fact that people in hong kong seem to
think that it's over
and um there have been a lot of whispers
about
uh the political repressiveness in hong
kong
being actually even more repressive than
in mainland china
so the direction of travel and the
direction that hong kong is going in is
deeply concerning
and it's really a cautionary tale for
taiwan yeah i mean that was
literally the next jump i was making is
taiwan considers himself
to be a sovereign nation uh china
considers them to be as you know
a province uh i think it would be the
word they would probably use or
part of mainland china um but the
taiwanese are proud people
what do we think that china
is going to do to taiwan what they
just did to hong kong well we know that
china considers taiwan as part of
their sovereign territory and we know
that
china has been in recent weeks uh
engaging in a buildup of amphibious
military equipment in its southern uh
coastline near uh
near taiwan uh right off the right
across the strait
uh from the the south china sea so
uh i think i think those two facts alone
are are pretty concerning and
china taiwan uh you know hong kong a
finance center
uh a an international hub for travel
and commerce that can easily be moved
uh you know relatively speaking taiwan
in terms of
semiconductors and chip manufacturing
not easily
replicated in other places so maybe you
could speak to
you know the fact that australia japan
and singapore and every other country in
korea every other country in the region
is chomping at the bit
to get expats out of hong kong give them
asylum visas citizenship a path to
citizenship
that is uh you know what the free market
is doing
which in one way is i think a huge
punishment to china
does china care that if they lose that
finance center
and they lose that because it appears
that they do not care
about losing what was the the finance
capital of the region
china thinks in very long time horizons
and the chinese communist party cares
first and foremost
uh with retaining power and with
protecting the legitimacy of their
government
that's why they've invested so much time
effort and resources in propping up
their economy
and misrepresenting a lot of their
economic data
and in doing a lot of the various things
from setting up an incredibly
sophisticated surveillance state that
has cctv cameras with facial recognition
everywhere
that's de-anonymizing the internet
inside of china
to preserve their grip over political
power
and hong kong thumbing their nose at
china
even though it's just a million two
million three million people
uh depending on how you count the region
uh involved in the protests and
and and they look at that as an
existential problem in that it could
infect the mainland and that they needed
to squash it now
is that the correct interpretation of
why they did this
well the power of the example
fundamentally um this is about
the legitimate about democracy
undermining the example of democracy
undermining the legitimacy of autocratic
governments
uh democracies are premised on the idea
that
authority based on a single person on
arbitrary decisions
taken by a single person is illegitimate
so well-functioning prosperous
democracies
will always undermine the basic argument
for autocracy
the basic bargain that china has trying
to
has been trying to advance to its own
people is
yes we're an autocratic country but look
how much
technological and you know they would
argue human development progress we've
made
over the recent years we've lifted
people out of poverty we've built so
many roads and dams and bridges
and they try to show material progress
through very large infrastructure
projects
in order to justify their holdover power
in order to justify their
repressive regime and they're not wrong
they have been incredibly effective at
moving people from poverty and not
having electricity or
water to having apartments and having
jobs and creating a middle class that
just
is the middle class in in china is
larger if i'm wrong than the entire
united states now so
as a market and as uh you know a
standard of living
they do have the high ground to say that
and the counter argument
that people put up there is hey this is
this is a country that's existed
for much longer than democracies in
america have
obviously not as long as democracy back
to the greeks um
or is that right uh yeah i mean the the
the idea here
is that you would
uh you're getting such a huge benefit
that unless you're just a troublemaker
you have nothing to worry about the
standard of living is going to keep
going up
how long can that narrative exist before
you know how long can people be
oppressed
and watch people go to jail because they
have a private
wechat group or they read a book or they
got a vpn
because it seems to me that china
could implode and have a revolution at
any moment
if their fac if they if we get kicked
out of china and we don't make iphones
there and they can't sell iphones
i i think they have a revolution am i
wrong or crazy
the the weakness of autocracies is that
because they're so much more centralized
than democracies
they're inherently also more brittle and
that's why xi jinping has placed such
a single-minded focus on
learning from the lessons of history of
the collapse of the soviet union
to avoid the same fate